[Music]
hello everyone it's great to be here
with you all today my name is Phil Adams
and I'm a researcher here at Google and
I'm P Allison software engineer at
Google we are here to talk to you today
about how we're rethinking app
distribution on Google Play we'll talk
about the new app publishing format that
we announced at i/o and share some new
features that we've been working on
digging deeper into some of the topics
that you saw covered during the keynote
to start with let's talk about app size
and the impact that it's having on your
app why does app size even matter we
shared this chart at Google i/o and you
saw it earlier today play store data
does show that when the app gets bigger
install success rate goes down many uses
don't have enough space left on their
device and especially in emerging
markets data can be expensive and
connection speeds slow I want you to
think about your own experience too how
many of you have seen a warning from
play to uninstall apps millions of
people see things like this every day
we've started looking into this area
more closely and we have found that
freeing up space is a major driver of
uninstalls
this is obviously a problem for people
with low storage devices but it's also a
problem for people with high end devices
who fill up their devices with HD
content check the US and the UK
one in five example one in five devices
have very low storage and are reaching
the limit where they can't install or
update a key request we hear from
developers is also for help
understanding and reducing and installs
we run a user research study last year
to look into wide users in the US and
install apps the leading reason ads were
uninstalled straight away within a day
was quality however the leading reason
absol gebbs were earning installed after
a month was to free up space absent
games keep getting bigger since 2012
absent games have grown over five times
on average newer devices have more
storage
but the apps games Harry's photos and HD
videos keep getting bigger - making you
a big puts it at risk to suffer from all
these downsides bigger app lose
acquisitions and bigger apps also get
uninstalled to free up space I'm sure
you already know that and you've
probably just considered it a trade-off
do you add new features and support more
device configurations but lose installs
and drive more and installs we don't
want you to have to worry about these
trade-offs for a few years there has
been a way to optimize for device
configurations you can use multiple apks
but it's incredibly inefficient and it's
a painful process this is what it looks
like in the Play console when you have
to upload dozens of apks for single
release the number of apks grows quickly
across dimensions for example 64-bit 32
bits and all the screen densities and
you have to version every APK for each
release it also doesn't help with some
of the dimensions for example all the
languages are still in all apk in every
apk we can do better let us show you the
solution that we have built for this and
see how the new app model helps make
your life easier so the new app model is
focused on improving the whole user
acquisition journey from discovery
through to retention
it helps by making your app smaller
directly improving install and uninstall
rates and in addition to that it makes
your releases more manageable in that
context for the rest of today's session
we'll talk about three important steps
that we want to help you with first we
want to help you convert more installers
and minimize uninstalls
by building smaller apps then we want to
make it possible for you to deliver
different features to different
audiences on demand only for those users
who need them and finally we want to
help you keep your users up to date on
the latest and greatest versions of your
app let's start with how to make your
app smaller this is where we began with
our major announcement at i/o about the
Android app bundle that bundle is the
official
Android app publishing format apps that
have already adopted the bundle are
seeing an average-size saving of 35
percent that's compared to a universal
apk and that's quite a lot
how does adopting a bundle lead to such
savings here's the big idea Google Play
can assist and take care of delivering
just what's needed to each device on
your behalf there's no need to send a
bunch of languages and device resources
which are not necessary we support three
slicing dimensions out of the box
languages screen densities and CPU
architecture all of this is made
possible by split apks a feature we
added to the android platform in android
lollipop
split apks allow multiple apks to be
installed on a device and behave as if
they're part of the same app these split
apks can be installed in different
combinations on different devices and
can be installed all at once upfront or
overtime piece-by-piece
given a bundle Google Play starts by
putting everything that is common to all
devices in the base apk this includes
the Android manifest and the Dex files
for instance we then generate a
different split apk for each screen
density each split will contain all the
durables that would have been selected
by the android framework on that device
with that density we then also generate
different split apks for each in native
architecture and we can generate a
separate split for each language
supported by your app putting each
languages strings in a different apk
together we call these splits
configuration splits or config splits
now when we go to serve an app to a
device we only need to serve a subset of
this place so if Phil for example has a
Samsung Galaxy j5 we will install the
base apks as well as the xhdpi density
split the armor cubes architecture it
splits and the English language split
but it can get a bit trickier than that
I speak both French and English and I
have specified both languages in my
device settings
so my pixel to excel will not only
receive the correct density and
architecture split but also the French
and the English language splits and if
the if I then move to Brazil and learn
Portuguese I might add Portuguese as a
language on my device when I do this the
Playstore will attempt to download the
Portuguese language splits for all the
apps on my phone for devices pre L which
don't support split apks play will
generate a matrix of stand-alone apks
for each combination of ABI and screen
density density that your app supports
each of this apk contains all the files
necessary for the device so my old
Galaxy Nexus still running Android
KitKat would receive the hdpi and arm
apk note that all the languages are
included in those apks putting it all
together the picture looks like this you
actually don't need to worry about all
the details of how these ATK's are
generated all you have to do is upload a
single app bundle and play generates and
select the right things to serve for
each device to summarize the app bundle
contains everything Play processes the
bundle generates optimized apks and then
signs each apk to deliver to user
devices note that because play is now
signing the apks this means that you
need to upload your signing key to
Google Play this is part of the program
called app signing by play in
conversations we've had with developers
they've asked a reasonable question is
this secure the answer is absolutely as
you can imagine Google takes this very
seriously
we protect your key in the same storage
we protect Google's own keys we have
engineers for custom security and you'll
benefit from our ongoing investments
we've been chatting to developers who
are already using the app bundle about
what they like recently we've conducted
a workshop with some developers from
India who make really popular apps these
developers have millions of active
installs and they're very sophisticated
about keeping their app size small
because their users are very sensitive
to it so this is a useful group for us
to learn from rio5 found that smaller
installs improve their conversion rates
Redbus speaks to their release process
being most streamlined and easier to
manage and swiggy reports that switching
was a simple process and they were
testing using a bundle within an hour
and it's not just developers in India of
course all these developers around the
world have switched and are seeing
fantastic size savings duolingo for
example so our 56 percent size saving
compared to a universal apk and it's
really hard to get such big savings from
incremental optimizations switching to
the bundle is the simplest and highest
impact thing that most developers can do
to reduce app size Google apps are also
adopting the bundle in production and
they're seeing strong savings as well
Google Maps is saving about 15% in size
YouTube 20 for Google News 27 they also
report some streamlining of their
release process and have even noticed a
lift in update rates so you can see this
isn't experimental this is ready there
are thousands of apps thousands of app
bundles in production and it's time for
all developers to start moving towards
this new publishing format so when you
adopt the app bundle
you're not only gaining size savings
today you will also be benefiting from
optimal Optum attic optimizations in the
future as Play introduces them here is a
cool example of another optimizations
we're just introducing we've added a new
Android platform optimization to the
bundle called uncompressed native
libraries his already work on Android L
and below native libraries have to be
uncompressed from the apk before the
platform can use them meaning the user
ends up with two copies of the library
after Android M the platform can read
the library directly from the apk if
it's left uncompressed thus saving a
copy on the device to do it yourself you
will need to need to avoid two versions
of your app and create multi apk for pre
and post M if you're using the app
bundle you just give us your libraries
and we and we create the required flavor
for pre and post m and serve the right
apk to the right user the size savings
were seeing on average are sick
Americans around 16% reduction in size
on disk and 8 percent reduction in
download size as I explained the app is
smaller on disk because the platform
does not need to make a copy of the
library but the download size is also
smaller because our compression
algorithms perform much better on data
that is not already compressed our
partner Gameloft so size savings on disk
of 22 percent and 16 percent on the
download size for the game My Little
Pony using this optimisation in the app
bundle and these savings are in addition
to the size saving they already sing for
from switching to the app bundle with
this optimization the downloaded size is
smaller it's faster to install and takes
up less space on disk if you're using
the app bundle you get this new
optimization without any extra effort
now we still want you to remain in
control to when these optimizations
should be pushed to your users for that
reason Play will only apply
optimizations on app bundle that have
been built with the version of Gradle
that introduces the optimization for
example the uncompressed native
libraries optimization will only be
applied to your app if you build it with
the latest Gradle 3.3 which is already
available for download in beta now let's
take a look at how you can build test
and publish Android app bundles you can
build that bundles in a 3.2 stable
release of Android studio the build
process is very similar to building an
apk for most developers so it's easy to
switch for those who prefer the command
line or wish to integrate with automated
build systems the new Gradle android
plug-in provides a new set of tasks to
build Android app bundles as you'll
remember you would use the assemble
tasks on the command line for building
apks and now with the Android app bundle
you use the new bundle task similar to
assemble tasks bundle tasks also allow
you to build specific flavors the bundle
task will generate an android app bundle
and place it in the outputs folder with
the flavor and build type chosen
the build artifact is simply called
bundle AAB we do want developers to
retain control over their splits and so
for if any reason you need to disable
splitting by a particular dimension you
can do so using the new bundle block as
shown here Android studio and Gradle are
not the only ways that you can build
bundles today because the format and
bundle tool are open-source others are
already adopting them for example we're
excited to share that games using unity
can now boy it build Android app bundles
to unity added support in the 2018 point
3 beta release and you can join the beta
program now so now let's see how you can
adapt your testing with the app bundle
during the development phase when you
need to iterate quickly
you don't need to go through the app
bundle you can keep building apks
directly from studio much faster before
a release you may want to test the AP
case that would be generated from the
app bundle from studio this is as easy
as creating a new run configuration and
selecting apk from app bundle in the
deploy menu studio under the hood uses
the same tool platers to generate the AP
case so you will get high fidelity when
you want to share the AP case generated
from the app bundle say with your QA
team you can use the bottle to a common
line this tool is what play and Gradle
use under the hood to generate ATK's we
have open source panel tool to be
transparent about how we generate ATK's
and you can download the bono to library
on the github repo you see here Buono
tool generates what we call an APK set
archive which will contain all the APK s
for all the device devices that your app
supports we can share this archive and
still using bono tool you can install it
on a connected device which will
simulate what playe does when serving
ATK's to that device as you can imagine
an APK said can become quite big so if
you want to build the APK is only for a
given device configuration you can do so
by passing to bonnet all a device
specification in a JSON format we can
share that archive around which can then
be
stalled on the devices matching the spec
this is what the common line looks like
to build the apk said archived from the
app bundle in this case we're
instructing Bonnell tool to build apks
only for the connected device if you
don't have a device at hand if you're
generating the archive from a CI system
for example you can pass instead a
device specification in this JSON format
finally if you want a unique easily
shareable apk you can also choose to
build a universal apk this apk does not
use splits but it can be installed on
any device so it's very convenient for
sharing but the best way to test exactly
what your users will get is still to go
through the internal test track on the
Play console this way you are guaranteed
to get byte 4 bytes what your users will
get the internal test track is similar
to the alpha and beta tracks that you
then you may already be familiar with
but it differs from these tracks in that
there is almost no delay between the
uploads of the bundle and the update
being available on the testis device you
can see here how it looks in the Play
console you can create a list of emails
for up to 100 QA testers the QA testers
can then follow the opt-in link and
they'll receive automatically the latest
version we know that for some of you
these testing options are not ideal and
we see a gap in particular between
testing in Android studio and place test
tracks so I just want you to know that
we're thinking really hard about how to
close this gap so now you've built and
test bundles let's discuss publishing
bundles and also a new view that we've
added to the releases section in the
Play console we're starting to show an
estimate when we think that an app could
really benefit from using the app bundle
we'll take a common reference device and
calculate what you could save were you
to switch to the bundle once you choose
to switch you manage your release just
like you did with apks simply create a
new release and drop the app bundle in
the same location where you currently
draw your apks do note in order to a Joe
migration you can keep uploading apk
on your production track while you test
the bundle in a test track and when you
do this play is not going to re-sign the
apk we did this so that you can feel
confident trying out the app bundle with
a smaller number of users first without
affecting your current production user
base once you've uploaded it you review
your release you roll it out and that's
it I can't stress this enough as Pierre
mentioned there's no more multi apk to
deal with play console has created in
the background all the apks for the
devices supported for you now that
you've uploaded your app bundle and
players done this heavy lifting it would
be really nice to have an overview of
what play has generated for you to give
you this transparency we've built a new
tool in the Play console called bundle
Explorer which lets you navigate your
uploaded bundles and the generated
artifacts on the first screen a bundle
Explorer you'll see how much of a size
savings you've gained by publishing a
bundle of course this is going to be
different device by device and so we
calculate this using a popular device
configuration you can also see below a
list of device configurations and the
total size of the apk is served to those
devices if you click on View devices you
can see which devices are in each bucket
alternatively you can search by cell for
supported device by name to download the
set of generated apks that gets served
to that specific device and this is
particularly helpful for example when
you get a bug report for a particular
device so you can get the exact same
apks the play has served to it of course
we haven't forgotten about everyone who
uses our publishing api uploading
bundles is also available via the api
and automation and CI tools are already
adopting the bundle for example Fastlane
you'll find all the documentation at
these URLs to recap that's the latest on
the Android app bundle and how we're
making your apps smaller and release
simple and release is simpler the next
big change the app bundle introduces is
modularization and dynamic code loading
this is an approved safe way to load
features and functionality dynamically
making your app
even smaller at install time okay let me
tell you how it works
dynamic features offer yet another way
you can reduce the size of your app some
big features in your app may be used by
only 10% of your users so to avoid
having the 90 other percent pay the
price of disk space for a feature they
don't use you can choose to extract it
in what we call a dynamic feature
dynamic features can be installed on
demand when user requests them or you
can choose to defer installing them to a
later time when the app goes to the
background for pre L devices which don't
support on demand features we can fuse
the modules into the main app so they
delivered at install time all of these
use cases are supported in production
today with millions of users benefiting
already Facebook was actually one of our
launch partners and they are using
dynamic features in production across
their app portfolio let's take a let's
take a look at the story app size is
really important to Facebook they
evaluate the app size impacts of each
new feature carefully to ensure that the
benefit of the feature is worth the size
increase dynamic features means that
they can build new features without
increasing the size of apps like
Facebook and Facebook Lite at install
time dynamic features also help Facebook
with their high end device strategy
Facebook is able to deliver advanced
features to just supported devices and
they can also remove large features that
are not used often to avoid taking up
space on that device forever Facebook
has told us that dynamic features work
well when they're working on a new
feature that is separate from the main
app they can have a separate team of
engineers working on it we can then add
the app and they can then add it to the
app without increasing the base app size
at install time here are some of the
examples of dynamic features that
Facebook is added to their apps these
are all features that are in production
for example card scanning is a feature
that only a small percentage of
Facebook's users are using so moving it
to a dynamic feature avoids it taking up
two megabytes on every users device for
the lifetime of that app
another example is real-time
communication by moving voice and video
chat to a dynamic feature only users
with devices that can support them and
who actually want to use them need to
download it what might that experience
look like for a user let's take a simple
example imagine that you have a recipe
app and you want to keep the initial
download size small you observe that
while all of your users like to browse
for recipes only a small fraction of
them like to add recipes and you notice
that this functionality takes up
significant size in your app you can
choose therefore to break this feat this
feature out into its own module and
serve it only when needed we can see
what it looks like for the user or what
it might look like for the user here the
app opens and then the user goes to add
a recipe the app then requests that the
module be installed it's downloaded and
installed with progress visible to the
user and the new feature is ready to be
used after just a few seconds wait which
parts of your app might make good
candidates to be broken out as separate
features we think about it using this
Venn diagram if only a smaller fraction
of your users use this feature it could
be a good candidate especially if that
feature takes up significant amounts of
space and finally consider of users can
wait a few seconds before downloading
and using that feature if you're
interested in module arise in your app I
invite you to check out the plad 2.0
project so that some of our dev roles
have been working on and the associated
articles that they published the
describe how modularization was achieved
for the app now that we have covered how
dynamic features work let's see how to
create them to create a dynamic module
in Android studio 3.2 all you need to do
is use the new dynamic feature wizard
click on file new module then choose
dynamic feature module just type in your
modules name and Android studio will
generate a new dynamic feature for you
under the hood this is what studio does
in the manifest of your new module a
split identifier is added in this case
we'll call it add
Sippi this is how the Android platform
recognizes that although this apk has
the same package name it's still a
different module then a new module tag
element is added which allows us to
configure distribution aspects of the
module this tag is used by the Play
Store to read properties of the modules
of your app next you declare that this
module is an on-demand module by adding
the on-demand attribute meaning that it
will be only delivered to users devices
when you request it instead of at
install time note that on demand modules
are only supported since Android L so
you have to specify as well what place
should do with this module when it
generates the pre L AP case you can
choose to fuse that module in the base
apk or excluded completely and this is
configured using the fusing tag here's
an example with our recipe at in
addition to the base module we have two
dynamic features the ad recipe module is
marked with fuse equal true while the
other VR module is marked with fuse
equals false
and you can see that that play will only
include the address city module in the
pre L apk now let's look at the build of
Gradle files in the dynamic module you
can see a new Gradle plugin being used
called come and read dynamic feature you
also have to add the base module as a
dependency of this dynamic module to
access functionality from the base
module looking at the build Gradle from
the base module the only change is to
declare all dynamic modules this is to
instruct Gradle to make the resources
stored in the base module available to
them now that we've created our
on-demand modules let's write the code
to download them in order to interact
with the Play Store to request these
on-demand modules we have to use the
split install API which is part of the
play core library this is a Java client
library that communicates with the Play
Store via IPC the Play Store IPC then
communicates with Play servers the API
is structured using the same task
framework that you may be familiar with
from Google Play services and firebase
api's installation of splits is
coordinated by the split install manager
you construct a request with all the
modules that you wish to download and
then invoke start install to trigger the
Play Store to download and install the
splits required for the requested
modules for large modules you'll need to
obtain the user confirmation prior to
the download via their split install API
you'll need to do this whenever an app
requests more than 10 megabytes of
on-demand modules to be downloaded the
API allows you to listen for updates
throughout the download and install
process and display this progress to
allow to display this progress to users
here we show the download progress bar
an alternative option for installing
modules that aren't required immediately
is to use the deferred installation API
these will be installed at a convenient
convenient time for the user generally
when they aren't using the device and
are on Wi-Fi and charging and because of
this we allow you to install larger
modules up to 100 megabytes without
requiring user confirmation the split
install API also allows you to manage
your on demand modules you can see which
modules are installed and you can choose
to uninstall modules that are no longer
required by the app this will free up
reaches disk space for your users so
when installing an on-demand module on
N+ devices the app does not need to be
restarted code is available immediately
and new resources and assets are
available once you refresh the context
object however on Android L&M installing
splits requires the app to fully restart
to avoid this we include a split compact
library which emulates the installation
of splits on L and M until the app goes
into the background and we can properly
install it if you are familiar with the
multi decks support library you will set
up split compact in a very very similar
way let's have a look you have three
options to install split compacts you
can use the split compat application as
your default application or if you
already have an application you can
simply extend it and if none of these
options suits you then you can still
also choose to override the attached
based context in you
application and invoke split competitor
install now let's talk about versioning
when you release an update to your app
play will automatically update both the
base module and any unda main mode
jewels that are already installed so the
version of your modules are always in
sync partners tell us this is something
they really like about this model let's
now talk about the final step here
helping users update to the latest and
greatest version of your app you know
that play offers also update
functionality and many users do have
auto update turned on but not all of
them and in some markets it's not
uncommon for users to have Auto updates
turned on but for their device not so
you meet the requirements for the auto
update to take place for example they
may not connect to Wi-Fi I'm happy to
share that we're launching a new API
that helps you prompt users to update
without ever leaving your app you can
call this API to determine first if
there's an update available and then if
so you can show a prompt to your users
so that they can update the app in this
example the flow is designed for
immediate critical use cases such as
user privacy or revenue affecting bugs
it's a full screen experience where the
user is expected to wait for the update
to be applied it's an easy one for you
the developer to implement because we
take care of restarting the app for you
some of you have built similar flows for
yourselves but this is a standardized
method that you can use with very little
effort instead of that immediate update
you can also put together a flexible
update which does not have to be applied
straight away the really cool thing
about this API is that you can
completely customize the update flow so
that it feels part like part of your app
for example you may choose to nudge
users to update with an inline flow like
Google Chrome is doing in this example
once the user accepts the update the
download happens in the background so
the user can keep using the app and once
the update is complete it's up to you
and your app
to decide how to prompt the user to
restart or you can simply wait until the
app goes into the background always
closed by the user Google Chrome is
testing this now and we're inviting
early access partners to start testing
thus from testing this with us as well
talk to your BD manager if you're
interested let's take a look at the code
that allows that flexible you know in
app update to work first you can request
an instance of app update manager and
then request the app update info this
result is going to contain the update
availability status if an update is
available and the update is allowed the
return up app update info objects also
contains an intent to start the flow if
the app is allowed to start then you
extract this pending intent and you
start it this will start the download
and installation you can monitor the
state of an update by registering a
listener for status updates when the
download is complete you can in choose
again to install it directly or defer
the installation to a more convenient
time for example using a snack bar the
restart happens when complete update is
called so to recap this new API ensuring
your users get the latest update is
important and you can make that happen
by following some of these best
practices up here on the screen and also
by integrating with our brand new in app
updates API the API is available for any
app and so you can get started with it
in parallel to switching to the Android
app bundle and that's it we've now
covered how to make your app smaller and
create dynamic features using the
Android app bundle and how you can
ensure that your users stay on the
latest version of your app using the new
in-app update API if you want to come
and chat about any of this you can find
us at the office hours or the demos on
the Google Play stand today and tomorrow
also if you want to share about what
we've talked today with your team the
medium post at this link is a great
place to start
enjoy the rest of your day thank you
[Music]